This is the purpose of the experiment we're doing now
To investigate this, we need to compare it with an experiment without rice.
Say it and do it for comparison
A control experiment that I know nothing will happen
But this time it's good that the other party is c and you need to continue the part-time job Or else
you can't prove the need for the other party to be rice
[music]
Senpai  It's
amazing, I
can't get confirmation as to whether or not the regents that you guys were doing were acting on the intensification of the factor, so
the 22nd place in
behavior might be just a reference, but
let's do an experiment with
this guy.  Is
my
heart pounding at Himuro?
[MUSIC] The
same picture
[MUSIC
] Nm
Shiro This result is Yukimura Kaa A
woman's battle is fine It's too far behind and it's a beast so you're saying it's different
[MUSIC]
To be honest I wonder if
I'm close to my parents  The tension makes my heart rate
skyrocket, right?